okay now later
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's budget executive meeting
and item one is attendances i'm not
aware of any apologies but i know that
counselor whitson ah
isn't here but he's just asked to join
the meeting so um
we can press on with that um item two
is declarations of are there any
declarations of interest
on any items on the agenda
no okay item
three then is um the executive's budget
proposals 20 21 22 and
related issues and clearly we're going
to have a substantive debate on this
in the full council meeting starting at
seven so i wonder councillor ross if i
could ask you to move
um items a b c e
f and g however you wish to do so and
then i'll come to council
right to move item d please
certainly thank you very much if i just
go through so the executive aware of
what's needed of them at this
point of time the in terms of the
revenue budget report we're asking that
the executive recommended council that
approves the budget and notes other
issues related to the budget
we're asking the executive confirms that
in recommending the approval of the
budget is taken into consideration
the objective assessments set by the
director of financial systems
of the robustness of the budget
estimates and adequacy of the financial
reserves
which is section six and annex eight h
the executive's response to the scrutiny
committee's recommendations to the
budget proposals as included in separate
reports on this agenda
the council's public sector equality
duty and the results of
of the consultation on the budget
proposals where required
we're also asking the executive to note
the report of the treasury
management strategy and recommend the
council that approves it
including the policy on debt strategy is
set out in section three
investment strategy is set out in
section five
and the prudential indicators and
limited limits included in the
authorized limit
we're asking that the executive approved
the capital program as detailed in
appendix 2 of the report schemes to be
undertaken from the block budget
allocations reported in paragraph 21
and detailed in annex in appendix 4
however
noting the amendment added today to
reflect the changes made by the
government
the highways capital funding which has
reduced the expected grant funding by
1.53 million
the executive recommended the council
approved the capital strategy the
overall capital programme
the additional credential borrowing of
10 million pounds
and the prudential and local indicators
to the council for approval
the executive also recommends that
council approves the fees and charges
for
21.22 thank you
thank you councillor ross and before
putting all of the
various recommendations to um
the executive could i invite councillor
wright please
to cover up item d the strategic land
review programme
2021-2024 this is just the part one
section counsellor right please yeah uh
happy to move that item leader thank you
thank you okay um so
are there any questions or comments from
members of the
executive
no any questions or comments more widely
i suspect people may be
holding themselves back
okay yeah i'm a leader um
so we do have a question
and on section
strategic land review program which is
section
d it does appear at this point that we
are delegating the disposal
of all and i just need to be clear on
this because although we'll have a
debating council
uh we're delegating the disposable of
all buildings to the direct
a place anything above half a million
pound
it appears we are giving him and his
department
sole autonomy without reference back to
a member an executive member or even a
scrutiny committee
can we have some clarification on that
please yeah certainly counselor right
are you happy to
come in on that
sorry later i couldn't get the mute
button off i'm going to refer i was to
refer to richard for that one oh if
that's okay later
richard
thank you that is a standard delegation
that we use on the land review
program for those assets that have been
identified for disposable in the report
for approval to the corporate director
in consultation
to proceed with those disposals
so just to be clear then richard we
haven't given you
the authority to dispose of anything
that is not listed in the report and it
will be done in consultation with the
exact member
that's correct okay nathan did you want
to come back on that well to be
fair andrew it doesn't say that at all
at no point does it say
the uh that the direct replace will
refer to a member
which means and even if they did refer
to a member
they don't there's no reference to wider
members so us as elected members but not
on the executive
potentially anything could be disposed
of potentially
without reference so perhaps nathan
could you outline when you've
ever been consulted as an opposition
member on the disposal of assets or
indeed when any party was
on the disposal of assets because this
is standard so i'm slightly
confused by your concern the concern
the concern is there's no level of
scrutiny for the disposal of any asset
now maybe nobody's ever picked up on
this before but on reading it
anything over half a million pounds it
doesn't even have to go to screwing it
it could just be sold so the tunnel
technically could be sold
no well i i'm slightly bemused by that
response nathan because it refers
directly to the items listed in the
report
well it says so it's probably important
i think given some of the scare
mongering that has gone on in the field
of the disposal of council assets to say
that
if it's not listed in that report
richard is not able to accept to check
uh willy-nilly for um any of our
buildings and for further clarity
and just for the record that would
include flixton house
or oceanum town hall or indeed sail
waterside
well i i certainly thank you for your
clarity on the on those buildings there
but i would like uh personally i would
like it i i
i'm dave morgan would like hey i would
like to have him
included to have some real clarity on
this we're at this point now
it's not open to the debate i appreciate
i have to say i'm actually reading that
i would encourage other members
including labour members to read it
i that's caused me serious concerns
today as i glance
i initially just thought i'd glance over
it's not relative so thank you for the
time that you've given me today thank
you okay i remain quite confused by that
nathan because it is an approved list a
council will
tonight be approving the list of
properties in scope
so i'm amused as it's as if you seem to
think that yourself
or labor back ventures from what you've
just said would be personally managing
the disposal of
the contractual process which is
slightly bizarre
given that that's the sort of thing that
we pay officers to do the role of
members in this council all members not
just members of the executive
or indeed the shadow executive is to set
the strategy
which includes the sites to be disposed
and that's what this paper does
and the standard item to which you're
referring
is to delegate to the corporate directs
replace to manage that process for us
once the decision as to what is to be
disposed
is agreed this evening
section g says add two or substitute
sites into the program during the year
including any site where the anticipated
capital received will be five hundred
thousand pounds
so irrespective of the list we are where
we are and you're going to take the
decision
but that this this does not read and
maybe we nobody's ever picked up on it
but you know what it's alarm bells for
me
i take your part i take on board that
there is a list at the back
which seems quite reasonable but there
is a a paragraph in the first
sec page two that says anything can be
added or taken away from it
okay well like i say then we'll we'll
note that personally i'm comfortable
but this is something that we've had as
a long-standing arrangement that hasn't
been um complicit in enabling the
sale of council buildings without our
knowledge so i'm happy to move forward
on that basis is there anybody else that
wants to come in at all
no okay so the recommendations are
as per um items a to g
that can um i just want to double check
have we satisfied
any requirements that we have with
regards to
the amended highways issue agreement
jane happy that we've
covered that off yeah
okay perfect thank you okay um
so the recommendations are as set out in
the report can they be approved please
thank you and then um sorry i did only
say until item
g because that's what i had um in my in
my head
that i'm just going to double check back
on that um because
cancer evans had quoted from item g it
was item g
perfect um i'm not aware of any items of
urgent business and therefore i will
move the exclusion resolution as set out
on the papers and because we are virtual
i will read it that the public can be
excluded from this meeting during
consideration of the remaining items
of the agenda because of the likelihood
of disclosure of exempt information
which falls within one or more
descriptive category or categories of
the local government act 1972
schedule 12a as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order 2006
and specified on the agenda item or
report relating to each such item
respectively
and can that be approved by members of
the exact
no problem i'll let you know when it's
turned off